este símbolo pintado en Amarillo aparece
en decenas de paredes no solamente de
gersón sino de ciudades tomadas por las
fuerzas rusas pertenecen a las cintas
amarillas un gran grupo de partisanos
que han colaborado con las fuerzas
ucranianas para ayudar a retomar esas
ciudades que así han sido invadidas
al principio solo tenía pintura azul
porque la amarilla se había terminado
más tarde cuando compré pintura le añadí
el amarillo
por más de nueve meses tuvimos que
soportar todo lo que hicieron eso nos
hicieron la vida imposible de tantas
maneras intentaban minarnos la moral
para empezar fue muy duro ver a esa
gente moverse en la calle como
serpientes cuando entraban en los
almacenes con sus rifles de asalto y
todos se estremecía
en esta casa está representado una de
las complejidades que se vivía en gerson
y también de los peligros que corrían
los partisanos como se ve en la pared
está pintada la letra Z que significa
que quien vive aquí era colaborador de
las fuerzas rusas esta familia vivía muy
cerca de ellos lo que representa el
peligro que significaba para ellos
ayudar a las fuerzas ucranianas a
retomar
a vos alguien me contactó en Twitter y
me pidió ir a mirar con atención en un
lugar por aquí cerca Claro que nos dio
miedo era peligroso no sabíamos quién
era esa persona y luego cuando tuvimos
más contacto nos dimos cuenta que la
información era para el ejército
cada persona que traspasaba evidencias
ponía su granito de arena en esta lucha
Entonces cuando oíamos y veíamos que
había un ataque a los militares rusos en
cierto lugar entendíamos entonces que
ese también era nuestro trabajo cuando
esta familia empezó a colaborar con el
ejército ucraniano en verano empezó
también a conocer como el ejército ruso
entraba algunas de las casas hacer
requisas muchas veces cavaban en los
patios en busca de banderas ucranianas o
también de esos celulares donde pasaban
la información cada noche esperaban a
que llegaran esos soldados rusos con el
temor de que algo les fuera a pasar hubo
muchas lágrimas cuando nos encontramos
con los militares ucranianos en la plaza
y cuando los soldados le dieron una caja
de galletas a timor yo volví a llorar
inmediatamente